[Música]
a lo largo de los 10 años en los que he
estado he visto jóvenes moverse
protestar ante los gobiernos exigiendo
la acción climate he visto a los
gobiernos 195 países poniéndose de
acuerdo en un documento de unas muy
buenas intenciones firmaban un acuerdo
en parís en el año 2015 diciendo que si
debemos de hacer algo contra el cambio
climático y efectivamente están haciendo
algo este documento es bastante
importante le denominan el acuerdo de
parís en él decían claramente nuestra
intención es llegar al 2030 con un
aumento de temperatura menor a los 2
grados y en el mejor de los casos menor
al 1.5 grados también he visto a las
empresas generar mega proyectos de
energía renovable evito a varios jóvenes
generar innovación y generar
emprendimientos que buscan desarrollar
productos verdes he visto todo esto e
incluso he visto un aire de partirse
delante mío
a pesar de haber visto todo eso ya había
hecho las sumas y las restas como los
esfuerzos que creó muy pocos se logrado
hacer yo debo decirles que ha sido todo
insuficiente y ha sido insuficiente
porque nuestro actual sistema económico
no permite que lo sea verán en los
últimos 258 años es decir desde que
inicia la época con la revolución
industrial la primera a la fecha hoy
2018 hemos aumentado ya un grado
centígrado
este aumento de un grado centígrado ha
significado un importante efecto sobre
los ecosistemas
esto no sólo significa daños en la capa
de ozono daños en pequeños ecosistemas
marinos terrestre
inundaciones olas de calor no significa
que representan un reto importantísimo
para la humanidad nosotros las
sociedades
actualmente nosotros tenemos un sistema
económico que nos permite vernos como
consumidores sí claro pude haber dicho
de que la unidad sería nosotros los
individuos los humanos las familias pero
lo cierto es que desde nuestro actual
sistema económico basado en capitalismo
lo que buscamos es aglomerar mayores
cantidades de bienes y de servicios para
ponerlo a disposición de más y más
personas si esto ha tenido algunas
ventajas la primera es que tenemos mucha
abundancia de alimento es así de hecho
nosotros actualmente tenemos el
privilegio de incluso tener cadenas de
comida que tienen 24 horas del día sí
bueno no es exactamente el mejor
alimento pero alimenta el fin ya acabó
estas ventajas no las tenían la sociedad
de hace unos 40 años hace unos 60 o 70
años el alimento pues tendrías que
prepararte
y este tipo de comportamientos que hemos
generado a nivel social siguen creciendo
-claro está- nosotros tenemos mucho
alimento en esto también existen
sociedades que carecen de él tenemos
grandes poblaciones que carecen de
alimentos y más allá de eso estamos
generando marchas y masas de monocultivo
deteriorando claro la tierra rodando más
y más y más trigo soja arroz poder
nutrir a más y más personas
el aumento de 1 punto de 1.0 grados ha
significado por supuesto que tenemos
ciudades en riesgo no solamente por
inundaciones debido a grandes lluvias
como lo fue el niño costero ustedes
recuerdan que cuando tuvimos eso el año
pasado tuvimos un tema de abastecimiento
de agua en chiclayo durante dos días y
la gente se puso histérica la gente en
los centros comerciales incluso en el
maya en la mayor tienda de abastos que
no voy a decir el nombre la gente se
peleaba literalmente por una botella de
agua unas botellas de agua de dos soles
producto peruano y botellas de agua
francesas de 8 soles simplemente
desaparecieron de las góndolas incluso
una marca muy conocida con la quien
también he contribuido justo había
lanzado hace dos meses una botella de
aguas con sabores o sea ya no era
exactamente agua no
y todas desaparecieron
claro los pequeños empresarios de agua
en ese momento estaban muy felices
porque veían cómo producir para poder
atender las mayores masas de mercado lo
cierto es que sólo dos días de
desabastecimiento nos dio una clara
muestra de cuál sería el comportamiento
si es que nos falta hace algo qué
pasaría si mañana no tuviésemos las
mayores cantidades de alimento si mañana
no tuviésemos agua tenemos dos opciones
la primera es ir a los supermercados y
atacarnos entre todos para poder
conseguir la mayor cantidad de agua la
segunda y que quizá también sería
interesante de reunirnos mediante
vecinos y ver cuántas aguas tenemos
dentro de nuestra cisterna y ver cuántos
nos correspondería a determinando el
número de personas proporcionalmente y
racionalizarlo durante el mayor tiempo
posible
esa es una segunda alternativa pero esa
segunda alternativa comunitaria se opone
a nuestro actual sistema económico
porque más es mejor
verán el actual sistema económico nos
ven como consumidores y por tanto al ser
consumidores necesitamos pagar por más
bienes y por matt services todos
queremos tener el último ahí y muchos de
quienes tenemos el último iphone porque
me incluyo dentro de ellos
tenemos muy buenas intenciones e incluso
hay algunos quienes dicen sabes que voy
a estar el desprendimiento de los
materiales y voy a reciclar el 100% de
este teléfono y si es que si fuese que
es que sea perdiéramos incluso el
teléfono de la existencia de la tierra o
lo lanzaremos al espacio así reciclamos
el 100% de ese teléfono seguiríamos
contaminado porque para producir este
teléfono hubieron contaminantes en la
cadena de producción en la extracción
producción distribución consumo e
incluso en el descarga verán la solución
no es desaparecer el consumismo como tal
es encontrar una alternativa sostenible
y magnificar otro de los grandes riesgos
es el desabastecimiento alimentario como
les había comentado
tenemos un grupo de personas que si
apoyan los cultivos orgánicos y si
definitivamente son muy buenos pero una
de las debilidades de los cultivos
orgánicos es que nos dan grandes masas
de volúmenes de alimento la pregunta es
cómo podemos darle tantos alimentos
orgánicos a tantas personas y aquí es
donde entra nuevamente nuestros
económicos los alimentos orgánicos
tienen mayor precio y quiénes tienen más
dinero van a poder pagarlos las
consecuencias climáticas nos van a
afectar a todos eso es definitivo pero
quienes tengan más poder adquisitivo van
a ser quienes van a estar en mejores
condiciones de poder afrontar la escasez
de agua si a mí me han dicho muchísimas
veces por supuesto cristian tenemos
escasez de agua pero ya tenemos plantas
de desalinización de los mares es decir
si es verdad la gran proporción de este
planeta es agua y la pregunta es cómo
vamos a carecer de agua si somos casi
casi el 80% de aguas es casi imposible
lo cierto es que si es verdad somos gran
parte el problema es que la tecnología
para poder hacerlo es muy costosa y los
volúmenes de producción de
desalinización son muy escasos para los
volúmenes de población que actualmente
tenemos
la descripción de las especies en los
últimos 40 años en extinto el 60 por
ciento de los vertebrados a nivel
mundial
grandes masas de ecosistemas están
siendo destruidos e incluso se habla que
al llegar al 1.5 grados de aumento de
temperatura el 70% al 90% de los corales
van a morir y si llegamos a los 2 grados
el 100 por ciento desaparecerán
y el permafrost
son estos grandes casquetes polares que
se encuentran en nuestro planeta que
gracias al aumento de temperatura y el
derretimiento glaciar nos van a traer
unas consecuencias muy interesantes
resulta de que estos casquetes están en
nuestro planeta desde su propia creación
y claro el cambio climático no es algo
que lo inventado el hombre el cambio
climático siempre existido no es digamos
no es nuestra invención como muchas
otras si la diferencia está en que el
cambio climático se ha acelerado por el
hombre
eso ha significado por supuesto de que
el derretimiento de los glaciares nos
pone en un gran riesgo de vida de que
grandes toneladas de dióxido de carbono
están contenidas naturalmente por
supuesto debajo de hielo al derretirse
esa tonelada además de virus y bacterias
van a poder salir nuevamente a la luz
eso va a significar un nuevo riesgo pero
así como va a representar un riesgo
también va a representar una oportunidad
el documento que les había hablado que
el documento de parís
decía claramente de que debemos de los
países vamos a tener las mejores
intenciones en adaptación y mitigación
vamos a esforzarnos para poder reducir
la temperatura y aumentar perdón la
temperatura en un máximo de 1.5 para
dedos de 2.0 y en un 1 en el mejor de
los casos de un 1.5 grados hasta ese
momento se creía que 1.5 grados iba a
ser una alternativa pues medianamente
buena lo cierto es que llegar al 1.5
grados ya representa una gran amenaza
para la humanidad
es una amenaza porque claro para
nosotros los hombres el planeta pues
tranquilo el planeta está bien el
planeta va a terminar desarrollando un
nuevo en un nuevo proceso evolutivo
hasta llegar a una nueva etapa de
consolidación y estancamiento que es el
que actualmente vivimos sin embargo para
nosotros sí va a representar un riesgo
es verdad no toda la humanidad va a
desaparecer no es que los humanos se
vayan a extinguir eso es cierto pero
gran masa de población especialmente en
aquellos países en vías de desarrollo
como nosotros países costeros como
nosotros van a verse afectados llegar al
2.0 va a significar un aumento de
temperatura y por tanto va a significar
un aumento del 10 por ciento perdón de
10 centímetros del nivel del mar ustedes
dirán bueno no es tanto pero lo cierto
es que nos va a repercutir en más de 90
millones de personas en inundaciones en
países en vías de desarrollo
a 2030
y resulta que las naciones unidas tiene
un grupo de expertos por supuesto de
todos los países que se le denomina el
panel intergubernamental de cambio
climático
en español básicamente es los top top de
los científicos se reúnen para poder
cruzar sus estudios y determinar cuál va
a ser el comportamiento a nivel
climático de los siguientes años en
parís en 2015 la convención marco
elegido una invitación por favor denos
una información de cómo se va a
comportar el planeta en los siguientes
años
hace dos semanas acaban de sacar su
último informe se le denominó el último
llamado
este último llamado solamente nos dice
yo lo he leído pero básicamente la
síntesis es actúen ya que ya no queda
tiempo
esto por supuesto es un punto bastante
alarmante no solamente porque el 2030
está de aquí a 12 años a una nada y si
han notado en las diapositivas
anteriores habíamos aumentado en más de
100 años 1% perdón un grado centígrado y
en 12 años vamos a aumentar 0.5 eso
significa un comportamiento totalmente
radical
al comportamiento que generaciones
anteriores han tenido si nuestra
generación es la generación de mayor
consumo nunca nadie ha tenido tantos
bienes a su disposición y nunca nadie
tampoco ha asumido un riesgo tan grande
como él
el objetivo es claro debemos de contener
el aumento climático de la temperatura a
1.5 grados pero realmente el informe nos
dice que si seguimos con el
comportamiento que mente tenemos vamos
rumbo a los 3 grados eso significa una
distorsión total del comportamiento de
nuestra temperatura y por tanto una
destrucción de nuestros ecosistemas
representa también una oportunidad para
poder generar alternativas viables
nativa sí es verdad reciclar ayuda andar
en bicicleta es una muy buena
alternativa si utilizar el transporte
público es la mejor opción si quieres
trasladarse de un punto a otro de una
manera rápida es verdad debe de consumir
alimentos orgánicos debe reutilizar los
materiales pero si te das cuenta eso no
fue suficiente y no va a serlo nosotros
que somos actualmente la generación que
tiene la mayor cantidad de recursos que
ninguna otra ha tenido tenemos esta gran
posibilidad o sentarnos y cruzar los
brazos a esperar cuál va a ser las
poblaciones que van a morir primero o
decidir tomar las tecnologías que
actualmente tenemos y afrontar el reto y
si la solución al cambio climático no es
algo del otro mundo
parte de este informe indicaba cuál es
la recomendación que los expertos de
cambio climático nos daban
hasta hace un tiempo hace una semana me
ponía a realizar un poco de información
de los antes del proyecto marte y
también de los avances de las estaciones
de exploración en la antártida
porque bueno incluso pero tiene una una
tartera claro estas estas bases tienen
como principal objetivo la investigación
ver cuáles son los comportamientos
anómalos en estos espacios casi virgen y
marte por supuesto es comprobar nuevos
terrenos para poder migrar en algún
momento
y bueno ahora también ahí hay temas
incluso turísticos que ya están
apartados para amarte lo cierto es que
si hay posibilidades de poder ir a otros
planetas pero les aseguro que no todos
van a poder ir
el sol está seguro y ahí la bicicleta si
no nos va a dar
lo cierto es que para poder afrontar el
cambio climático no hay que hacer una
mayor ciencia porque la ciencia ya se ha
inventado las plantas de desalinización
y existen las plantas de energía eólica
ya existen y el sol con nuestros paneles
solares ya existe lo que tenemos que
hacer es migrar esa migración la tenemos
que hacer en 12 años en 12 años tenemos
que reducir el 45 por ciento de lo que
hemos emitido en comparación a la época
preindustrial y a partir de 2050 tenemos
que ser neutros es decir cualquier
contaminación que generemos debemos de
neutralizarla
la educación ambiental es importante si
las charlas como éstas son importantes
sí pero mucho más importante es tomar
acción antes
por supuesto de que los gobiernos tienen
la intención de poder invertir en cambio
climático el cambio climático es caro y
es caro por las consecuencias una cosa
es tener una ciudad y mantenerla
mediante los impuestos y otra cosa es
afrontar una crisis en inundaciones con
olas de calor con derretimiento de los
glaciares y por tanto con inundaciones
y los fondos para poder hacer una
reconstrucción de una ciudad son altos
de hecho nosotros ya hemos destinado
fondos en el norte de perú por el tema
del niño costero como había comentado
pero también existen beneficios
intrínsecos a la lucha contra el cambio
climático parte de ellos por supuesto es
que si mejoramos las condiciones
climáticas el aire va a mejorar si
mejoramos el aire nuestra salud va a
mejorar si luchamos contra el cambio
climático las condiciones de los suelos
van a mejorar y por tanto vamos a tener
mejor rendimiento de nuestras tierras
esos beneficios van a significar ahorros
futuros es un tema simple cómo esto se
mueve por economía esto es simplemente
inversión invirtamos en cambio climático
quizá esa ahora sea la mejor alternativa
y por supuesto necesitamos una amplia
participación
ya no se trata de hacer pequeños
proyectos ahora tenemos que hablar de
grandes masas de proyectos no debemos de
hablar de colectivos de pequeños grupos
de jóvenes de grupos indígenas no es
también la subsistencia de estas
minorías ya son buenas pero necesitamos
movernos masivamente hacia una economía
sostenible
no sobre un sistema sostenible sobre una
economía que nos permita volcar todo
nuestro sistema hacia un nuevo sistema
que nos permita tener una economía
circulante y ya no lineal como la que
actualmente tenemos y supuesto optimismo
si toda la información científica nos
dice que todo está mal
en serio todo está mal
y yo en más de una ocasión lo he pensado
hacer
pero sin optimismo no vamos a poder
afrontar esto asuman el reto el reto del
cambio climático
[Aplausos]